this should probably go without saying
but bill gates did not create
the coronavirus that causes coven 19
nor did he engineer a pandemic in order
to depopulate the world
and yet conspiracy theories saying just
this
are everywhere on social media not just
in the united states
but around the world on a variety of
platforms
here ford's contributor bruce wiley
who's a healthcare researcher
studying this and previous pandemics
talks about these conspiracy theories
why they're so dangerous
and why people believe them if you look
at this pandemic
you've got the virus spreading but
what's actually been spreading
in some ways much faster than the virus
itself has been these
conspiracy theories it's good to have
theories like you don't want to sit
there and say
i accept the world as it is i'm not
questioning
i will do whatever i'm told but you have
to go through the steps you've got to
say okay let's test it first
and then let's see what evidence and
let's be very transparent let's be open
about what the limitations are
and some of the theories and some of the
questions people questioning things and
suspecting
conspiracies we think have actually
turned out to be correct
there was the concern for a while that
tobacco companies were covering up
the risks of uh smoking and eventually
there was
studies which showed yes yes there was
knowledge that
smoking can lead to cancer the problem
with the conspiracy theories
is they'll advance the theory without
the evidence they won't say
okay this is the evidence that i came up
with
this is actually the weakness with this
theory the limitations
instead you hear this is what happens
trust us
or there's no mention of like oh we may
be wrong
or there's no mention of okay these are
limitations of the theory that's how you
really distinguish between a conspiracy
theory
and a theory but the risk with these
conspiracy theories is they can distract
and they can
pull attention away and they can waste
time from actually providing solutions
so people talking about like these
conspiracy theories
about the origin of the virus when we
actually really need to focus
more time and energy and come up with
solutions
you know even if you were to prove a
conspiracy theory to be correct
like how does that change the actual
situation right now like how does that
change the fact that this virus is
circulating
and that we don't have a vaccine for it
and that we don't have a specific
treatment for it
it'd be equivalent to like say we're
playing in like a basketball game
and we're behind we need to score and
someone's saying hey you know that
basketball looks like it's from mars
maybe we shouldn't investigate the
basketball being from mars
you'd be like dude we need the score
okay we need to catch up it's the same
situation here
conspiracy theories can actually
stigmatize certain
groups of people and certain individuals
and
bring on negative stereotypes that are
not warranted so accusing particular
groups of people
or particular individuals for this
pandemic when there's no real scientific
evidence
can raise the ugly specter of bigotry
and racism or
try to decrease uh people's trust in
certain groups like the medical
profession or scientists
and then people then come up with these
very grand statements like saying
i don't trust the media well the media
is not like one big large
clump of people the media actually
there's many different types of media
there's many different reporters
etc but like you'll see that people
start thinking
completely binary like okay i can't
trust
anyone i can't trust the government i
can't trust
anyone with two legs then you know where
are we left we're left in a situation
where
everyone's paralyzed because they don't
know what to do so
those are the dangers of these
conspiracy theories
and they're real dangers but the
challenge is some of these conspiracy
theories are being very aggressively
spread
by things like bots they're very well
orchestrated
maybe the social media platforms you
know should they have a role in terms of
regulating what is actually just chatter
and talking and what is
actually deliberate attempts at
propaganda
that's not justified by science it's no
longer a free speech issue it's actually
what do you do about people who are
actually trying to deliberately spread
things
setting up situations where you can
identify these possibilities
uh may be reasonable because again
you're not just talking about individual
people
uh talking or wandering or musing you're
talking about actual deliberate attempts
to use
these platforms